now
a gruesome discovery our eight news now
i-team told you about first police
finding a severed head in a stolen truck
now at six the startling photos and
video our i-team is now uncovering i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis the 8
news now i-team's david charns here in
studio with evidence in the case you
will only see on 8 news now brian denise
these pictures are simply shocking and
disturbing the 8 news now i-team first
breaking this story back in december
police believe a man shot his friend
bought supplies to dismember him and
then drove around with those body parts
a disturbing discovery in the back of
this truck detectives with las vegas
metro police finding a missing man in
pieces they lay out their findings in
these grand jury transcripts in the
murder case against 58 year old eric
holland holland seen in this new photo
during his arrest accused of killing and
dismembering this man 65 year old
richard miller miller lived on a
houseboat on lake mead documents
revealing police believe the two men got
into an argument in november then miller
disappeared
as part of their investigation officials
with the national park service say they
spoke to a man they knew as brian long
this is his license police say brian
long is really eric holland who is using
an alias
prosecutors say this video shows him
soon after miller's disappearance on
november 23 at a las vegas home depot
buying a saw and trash bags
investigators say they found the saw and
those bags with pieces of miller in them
in the back and in the open tailgate of
this truck
as the eight news now i-team reported
police started chasing holland on
december 23
driving what they say was a stolen truck
this video shows holland pulling into
the rio hotel during that chase police
losing him as he switched cars in the
garage prosecutors say this surveillance
video shows holland getting into a
different truck the one police say they
found the body parts in and then driving
to an apartment complex nearby documents
revealing officers tased him and during
an inventory of the truck police say
they found miller's remains
i can't read it because they broke my
glasses and i don't have any glasses in
court earlier this year holland's lawyer
said his client wouldn't lead police on
a chase had he known what he was
carrying around
right now holland remains in jail where
he's being held without bail he's due in
court later this month i'm david sharon
is live local now